Yeah. So, go ahead. What's the next
point? I forgot. We were
>> So, yeah, as far as as far as uh Issa's
main points. So, um if he really
believes in Muhammad and if he has a
good reason to believe in Muhammad, he
could take it by faith that that
Muhammad is um is related to to Ishmael
and that there's some uh there's some
connection to Abraham there. Uh but, you
know, he he would have to call that a
kind of leap of faith. So we we can
actually look at some of these other
reasons and uh Sam what what do you
think about the points about Isaiah
Isaiah 42 because this is this is a this
is a popular one. So there are a couple
of issues here namely whether whether
the teachings of Muhammad and Islam are
in line with the teachings and theology
of the book of Isaiah. And then secondly
is Isaiah 42 about Muhammad? Is this
predicting an Arab prophet? And if if it
is predicting an Arab prophet, can we
say that that this has some
>> connection to Muhammad?
>> Yeah. See, now [clears throat] one thing
I think you would have you would agree.
If Isaiah is going to predict a prophet,
then the prophet that's going to come
cannot contradict what Isaiah believes.
So I'm going to go slow with this. You
even said Isaiah prophesied Jesus, which
is interesting because I'm going to show
you where we believe Jesus was
prophesied. But before that, and I just
want you to note these references down
unless you want to read them. In chapter
5 of the Quran, verse 18, surah ala
chapter 5:18. So I want to go slow so
you can keep up. I don't want to go too
fast.
>> Thank [clears throat] you.
>> Chapter 5:18, it says that the Jews and
the Christians said to Muhammad, "We are
the sons of Allah, his beloved." And the
responses say, "Why then does he punish
you for your sins? Nay, you are but
mortals that he created." So the Quran
says Allah is not a spiritual father to
the Jews and the Christians cuz
Christians and Jews do not believe God
is a physical being who has sex with
women to sire children. When when a
Christian or a Jew says God is my father
spiritually he made me he gives me life.
He protects me and he loves me like an
earthly father. But Muhammad said no
Allah is not your father. And then in
chapter 19
[clears throat] 88 to93 chapter 19 88-93
there it says that the highest
relationship you can have chapter 19 88
to93 slave to master. Allah is only your
your master your lord and all you are is
a servant slave. But in Isaiah 63 verse
16 and Isaiah 64 verse8 I can I can read
it for you so you know I'm not making it
up. Isaiah 63:1
16 and Isaiah 64:8.
I'm going to read those. This is what
Isaiah said.
>> Okay? [clears throat]
>> For you are our father.
Were Abraham not to know us, nor Israel
to acknowledge us. You, Lord, our are
our father, our redeemer. You are named
from of old. And then again, do not be
so very angry, Lord. Do not remember our
crimes forever. Now, because it's New
American Bible, it's a different
versification. You see,
>> because it's a Yeah, let me just check
it out cuz I I suspected they're
probably going to go with the Jewish
rendering. My My apologies, guys. Hold
on. Cuz the New American Bible does have
a different versification. So, here,
verse 7. Yet, Lord, you are our father.
We are the clay and you are powder. We
are all the work of your hands. So, it's
in verse 7 in the American Bible, but
other versions is going to be verse 8.
So, keep that in mind.
>> Yeah. Wait, can you repeat the verse
about the about the clay if you don't
mind?
>> Yes. Yes. Right here. It's Isaiah 64:7.
Yet, Lord, you are our father. We are
the clay and you are potter. We are all
the work of your hands. So Isaiah is
saying because God made us.
>> Yeah.
>> And he sustains us and he redeems us.
He's our father. So why did your prophet
reject that?
>> Can I make a quick point really quick? I
I think it it makes me smile some like
in a good way, right? when you said that
uh we you know we are the clay and then
God is is is the one who's making us
it's very interesting because the Quran
it says in surah alman that God created
us out of clay so again it really it's
interesting and it makes me smile to see
how the Bible in the Quran they every
day I read it it they always find a way
to just fit exactly
>> well Issa you're ignoring what I said
>> sorry I I let me let me address your
point
>> no but you're saying that clay it says
that Adam was created from clay but
Genesis 2 says from dust so They don't
agree. It's a contradiction. But let's
put that aside. So you say yes. That's
good. But let's come back to the issue
though.
>> Okay.
>> Isaiah said, and he's using the metaphor
of a potter and clay. So God is not
literally a potter. You're not literally
a cake clay. God's not going to turn you
into a vase. Right? This is a metaphor.
Metaphor meaning that God has fashioned
you and he's in control of your destiny.
And if you turn to him, then he will
bless you. Won't bring calamity. But
that's not the point. I want you to
focus on the point. You can go to the
clay analogy. It only shows that
Muhammad takes parts of the truth and
contradicts the rest. Since the God of
Isaiah is a father to his people, the
God of Isaiah is a father to his people
spiritually, not sexually.
>> Why is it then Muhammad says Allah is
not a father to the Muslim um and how
can he then be in agreement with Isaiah
when Isaiah says he is a father,
Muhammad said he isn't? How can that be
a prophet mentioned by Isaiah?
>> Okay. Okay. So, so your [snorts] so your
claim is how can the prophet peace be
upon him
>> be a prophet when when he goes against
Isaiah is is that the am I clear?
one other aspect but this right where
>> okay as a human being
>> who was born I I don't know right it's I
I only Allah knows but but I just have a
similar point I have I want to make a
point the fact that we don't know right
so when Jesus when the of course my you
can correct me if I'm wrong but when the
Jews asked him you know these this
couple has committed adultery what
should we do according to the law of
Moses what should we do so we they
should be stoned
And then Jesus said, "Let let he who is
without sin throw the first stone." So
is Jesus not contradicting the Torah
there. Because
>> yeah, you confused two issues. You've
confused
>> abrogation with the nature of God.
They're not the same. But even in John
8, no, they didn't bring two people.
That was Jesus's precise point. You're
referring to John 7 53 to 8:11. They
only brought the woman. And only
bringing the woman, and this is where
you're going to see why Jesus said what
he said. He caught them in their lie
because the law says you got to bring
the man and the woman to be stoned.
Instead, they brought only the woman
caught in adultery, which means they let
the man go. So Jesus right there was
showing their hypocrisy. You're not in
line with the law of Moses because if
you did, if you actually cared about the
law of Moses, you would have brought the
man that she committed adultery with.
But in not bringing the man, you are in
sin, in violation of the law, you
hypocrites. Get away from it.
>> I see. Okay, that
>> that's what Jesus is doing there. But
don't forget, there's a difference
between I'm not trying to cut you off. I
want you to understand a difference
between
>> commands and legislation for a specific
period of time and the nature of God.
We're not talking about legislation.
Because even as Muslims will tell you,
abrogation
only relates to commands. But you can't
abregate a fact about God's nature
because God's nature doesn't change.
Whereas commands can change because of
circumstances that change. So since God
has always been a father, he was a
father in the Old Testament. He's the
father of Jesus and believers in the New
Testament. How then can Muhammad be a
prophet like Isaiah when he says, "My
God is not a father." But Isaiah says,
"No, my God is a father.
[sighs]
Okay.
All right. Let me uh
let me think this over really quick."
Okay. So it's all about
So of course I don't know the exact
truth, right? But I know that [snorts]
God when he reveals a verse in the Quran
or when he when he wants to send down
when he let me see I want to word this.
I don't want to say anything that is
wrong.
But everything he would do had has a
purpose has a purpose to it, right?
Everything. So when he calls himself the
father and then we are like his his u
figure uh figuratively speaking his
children, right? And then in the Quran
when he says uh Allah is the father to
no one, right? Of course I believe uh
that that all happens that all was
revealed for a purpose, right? So we dis
we disagree with each other for a
reason, right? And God doesn't make
mistakes. It's not like he made a
mistake with the verses, right? It's
like you believe that he was a father. I
believe that uh the uh uh theoret uh
figuratively speaking, then yeah, we are
children, but not not literally. But
when it comes to uh that verse or that
Muhammad peace be upon him not saying
that we're all that we are uh that we're
not children of God [snorts] of course
that does go against Isaiah
[clears throat] and of course uh the
prophets do need to go in line with each
other. When I mean they go in line with
each other, I mean with with like very
strong like beliefs like like he is one
like God is one or uh uh a message that
god uh gave an old testament prophet
would it should be in line with the new
testament prophet. Now in I mean sorry
with uh Muhammad or any other prophet
that would come after them. So I do know
um the message that the overall message
that was given to the Old Testament
prophets are in line with with what the
prophet received. I do believe that. And
just because uh uh a few verses don't
line up, all of that has to do with with
what was meant to happen. Right? So
these verses were supposed to go against
each other. Not not that we could
explain them, but that's so we could
fathom and wonder, you know, why. You
know, I don't know why those verses are
different. I can't I couldn't answer
that. No, no Muslim in the world could
answer that. I don't know. That's my
answer.
>> I just want to ask him this though.
Could you say like Isaiah says or
Christians say, could you say it? And I
know you can, but I just want to see if
you could you say, "Oh Allah, you are
our father. You are my father in
heaven." Like Isaiah said, like Moses
said, like Jesus said, like his father
say. So, can you call God your father
like they did? And if not, why not? Cuz
you're following a man who doesn't allow
you to do it. Whereas all the other
prophets says you can call him that. So,
can you say, "Oh, God. Oh, Allah, you
are my father."
>> I don't know the the the Islamic ruling
on it. I don't know like if if that like
is considered like a
>> No, you yourself, can you say it? Can
you mean say it and mean it? Then know
that God is your father in heaven.
Well, that's that's a bit of a that
would be hard for me to say because I
know if I say that, you might pull a
verse that would go against me. So, like
it's hard for me to say.
>> No, no, it's not going against you
because I'm telling you if you follow
the Bible and you follow the teachings
of Jesus, you could say that because I
want to read something for you.
>> In John 1, John 1 12-13.
John 1 12-13. But to those who did
accept him, meaning Jesus, he gave power
to become children of God, to those who
believe in his name, who were born not
by natural generation, nor by human
choice, nor by a dec man's decision, but
of God. So Jesus says to you, if you
come to me as a son of God, I will give
you the power to be a child of my
father, and you can call him my father,
but not if you follow Muhammad.
>> Okay? Um
so like I said earlier um I know that in
the Bible uh
some of uh some biblical figures are
called the God's slave right God's
servant the uh I know in the New
Testament I I believe it's let me find
it in the beginning says uh I forget his
name it says his name the a servant of
God and I believe it's I will find it
for you in just
>> we're we're not we're not we're not
disagreeing with you Yes, exactly.
People in the Bible are called servants.
It's it's that we have we kind of have
multiple relationships, right? Like you
like like like you you could be you
could be
>> a son of your father and yet work for
him. So you'd have you'd have two
separate relationships with with your
father. So So we we Yeah, we have we
we're not we're not challenging you. You
don't you needed you don't need to prove
it to us.
>> Okay. Okay. So my I mean I I guess this
is just one of the points where we we
disagree with and I guess it's going to
be hard to change anyone's mind, but for
me that's not like a a big enough like
pro issue for me to want to question my
faith. I understand you know when I was
a Christian uh yeah I believed God was
my father but when I after I converted
it it the relationship shifted. Not that
God was any less of a uh not that God
wasn't any I couldn't have a
relationship with him. Right? The hadith
I don't have the exact one but God says
if you come to me walking I'll come to
you running. If you come to me one
handspan I'll come to you one cubit. So
like the relationship between God and
and and me never changed. I saw the
strong relationship.
>> You just said you used to call him
father and you're a Christian. If it
didn't change why did it stop?
>> And and before you answer that let me
tell you why it is a major difference.
It's not minor. We'll go to something
else. But
>> it is major. It's not minor because yes,
every child is a servant to his parents
because you serve them. So part of being
a child is you're also a servant.
>> It's not a contradiction. But all you
are is a servant no more. But a son is a
servant who's more than a servant. And
here's what Jesus said. So it's not
minor. It's major because shows that
Muhammad doesn't follow them. Because in
John 8, John 8:34-36,
John 8:34-36,
this is what Jesus says. Jesus answered
them, "Amen, amen, I say to you,
everyone who commits sin is a slave of
sin. A slave does not remain in a
household forever, but a son always
remains." So if a son frees you, then
you will truly be free. Jesus said, "No,
it's major. If all you are is a slave,
you have no guarantee you're going to
remain in the house. But if you're a
child set free by the son, then you have
a permanent place in your father's
house." But you just said, "I used to
call him father, but now as a Muslim, my
relationship's the same." But you don't
call him father. No, your relationship
has changed. It's like saying to your
dad, "I used to call you dad, but now no
more. I won't call you dad, but our
relationship is the same." That doesn't
work.
>> Okay. Uh, and of course, we we we both
have a different uh difference of
opinion when it comes to that. Um, all I
can say I don't I don't know exactly how
I want to go about in addressing these
because these this is uh I mean I I did
I did definitely did not come prepared
for this exact this exact conversation.
>> But if I mean if it's all right with
you, I feel like we could talk about
that topic all all day and then we it
would be hard. Yeah. And and of course
nothing uh not not to like uh bash the
topic. It just I personally I feel like
it can go on forever and it would be
hard to answer. But my like sort of
final statement would be uh if this
makes any sense of course I know it
would be hard to relate to you but in a
way I I feel my relationship with God
has got stronger ever since I am am his
slave. That's how I feel. If I'm you
know like when I wake up for morning
prayer before the sunrise I force myself
out of bed because I'm his slave. I
whatever he wants me to do I would do.
If he wants me to wake up before the
sunrise and pray that's what I do. If he
wants me to stay up late to pray that's
what I do. If he wants me to fast all
day that's what I do. I am whatever he
commands me to do. And that's what I
that's that relationship for me has
gotten me stronger with him. And of
course, everybody's different. Everybody
has different uh uh beliefs when it
comes to that. But my sort of like
statement with that would would be my
ending statement would be that for that
topic.
>> Let me uh let me uh let me mention uh
let me mention two things here and then
we can uh and then yeah, we then we'll
they'll we'll move on on this issue. But
uh in in in Issa's defense, he he he
basically pointed out, yeah, there is
some issue there with uh you know, with
God being our heavenly father in both
the Old Testament and the New Testament,
but not in Islam. Uh but he pointed out
it's kind of not it's it's not enough a
big enough issue to sort of bother him
about Islam. And and I would go back to
what I said earlier that if you have
good enough reasons to believe something
then when something else comes along and
and and casts doubt on it then you know
if you're if you're if you're
considering the evidence in a scales
well yeah I see that as a problem. I see
that problem over there but I have this
better evidence over here. And so again
you could take these leaps of faith on
various issues as long as you have good
reasons um to to back up what you
believe. But I also want to point out uh
Issa that that this is this is actually
we believe this is actually a huge issue
that that God because it's it's
connected to all kinds of other things.
the the status of God as our heavenly
father versus our pure slavery in Islam
>> is connected to all kinds of other
things for so for instance it's if you
think about it um a parent who has a
child the parent just automatically
loves his or her child right it's just
that's that's the way it is I love my
son or my daughter doesn't matter if he
does something wrong I still love my son
or or my It's not that, you know, my son
was just born and I'll wait 15 or 20
years to see if he turns out good. And
if he turns out good, then I'll love him
because he's earned my love.
>> Whereas with a slave, if you were to buy
a slave,
>> you don't you don't you don't love that
slave. You don't love that slave. That
slave, you could grow to love that
slave, right? You could say, "Man, this
is the best slave ever. I really I
really love my slave." But there you
would be earning it. And so the reason
I'm pointing this out is if you look at
the Bible and the Quran, and this isn't
simply a matter of calling God our, you
know, our our father. It's in the Bible,
we love God because God first loved us.
So God starts this off. It's not us
earning God's love. It's we we're our
righteousness is as filthy rags before
God. We're not good enough. He loves us
because he's our our heavenly father. In
Islam, notice what you have in the
Quran. You have to obey God first and
then he will love you, right? You obey
God tells you what to do and then you
have to go out and obey him. And if you
obey him enough,
>> then he might love you. And so you have
to show yourself. In other words, he
doesn't love you automatically. You have
to go out and show that you're like the
a really really good slave and then
he'll love you. So and the point is this
isn't simply a matter of thinking of God
as a father or thinking of God as a
master. This is connected to all kinds
of things. It's connected to ethics and
so on because if if I view other human
beings as people who are sons and
daughters of God, whether they recognize
it or not, then that's different than I
would view them as if I if I view them
all as rebellious slaves who God
despises and and has no love for. And so
it's kind of connected to all kinds of
things. Anyway, the point of all of that
was just
>> this is actually a really big issue. And
so all of these things are connected.
And so if God in the Old Testament is
the heavenly father and this is
connected to God's view of human beings
and human beings view of God and human
beings our view of each other and we
find it in the same in the New Testament
and then Muhammad comes along and he
says, "No, you you don't you don't have
that kind of relationship. The only kind
of relationship you can have is a slave
tomaster relationship." and therefore
you better be really good slaves. Well,
there might be people who who think, you
know, I'm going to work really hard and
I'm going to be a great slave. And that
could be a great that could be a great
motivator to get people to do what you
want. Uh only point is um I don't think
this is a this is a m a minor issue.